on a vu déjà en 2015 que la russie avait
fait sauter l'électricité pendant plus
de six heures pour une région
ukrainienne deux cent mille personnes
âgées
on voit des attaques sur les banques ça
se passe en fait de façon à ce qu'on en
voit un flux massif de données de
connexion sur un serveur phase one faire
sauter c'est pour ça qu'à des gens qui
peuvent lui retirer leur argent des
banques ont pu aussi derrière bien sûr
je pense qu'il faudrait réaliser
aujourd'hui que une guerre en 2022 ça
joue sur deux fronts iliad pour
militaire vous en avait parlé il ya peu
d'interaction de troubles mais il ya
aussi le plan cyber et si on y déniche
un je pense que malheureusement loupé
une lecture dax intéressantes sur cette
guerre et la russie aujourd'hui ils sont
capables d'aller très très loin en terme
de
cyberguerre allons clairement c'est
l'une des trois meilleures nations au
monde en terme de cyberguerre
aujourd'hui ils peuvent faire énormément
de choses que ce soit de la surveillance
sur les réseaux sociaux que ce soit
essayé d'attaquer des caméras de
sécurité il ya énormément de choses qui
sont faites en fait de façon c'est une
guerre d'intelligence en fait de
renseignement et aujourd'hui tout passe
par internet alors sergei on va on va
voir vous allez nous expliquer aussi
pour l'électricité dans un instant parce
que ça peut concerner tous les français
on peut se retrouver sans électricité ce
serait fou sergey quand confie-t-il
pourquoi les russes ils peuvent faire ça
aujourd'hui parce que on croit que
internet ça passe par les airs par les
satellites et en fait non ça passe par
guy % du trafic passe par les câbles en
dessous comme la semaine parce que en
fait le câble c'est la fibre optique
donc ça va à la vitesse de la lumière
parce que quand ça passe par les en fait
on perd énormément vitesse donc on a on
a trouvé ses solutions là mais la
faiblesse c'est aussi la même ça veut
dire que déjà ses dents dans l'océan
alors c'est dans l'océan donc comment il
parle quand il pourrait couper
l'électricité les rues baa série câble
s'est pas plus gros que les tuyaux
d'arrosage en est donc après peu après
il ya quand même bien évidemment des du
métal là dedans mais vous pouvez une
scie à métaux enfin une psy spécial
éventuellement et bouc volley le voulait
couper et surtout de truc c'est que
c'est des millions de kilomètres si on
ramasse tous les câbles de ses amis lyon
1,3 de kilomètres de câbles ça veut dire
trois fois à l'air autour sur eux sur la
lune un vrai mais il est ici coupe une
fois ces morts ça dépend où trouver
d'accord mais ça ou qu'on le perd depuis
les isabeau au groupe et surtout ccc
soumaré c'est sérieux ça mine
alors on part demain d'un ton grave mais
je suis mal il y en a ils coupent le
truc c'est fini plus d'enseignements
s'il n'y a pas de faire est ce que tu
penses que c'est kiki c'est poutine
donné sept ans non mais n'importe quel
ennemi d'autres d'autres puissances
peuvent aussi le faire mais disons que
poutine on sait que c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui se dit vous m'emmerdez ben
je vais vous vous emmerdez et donc ça
c'est une faiblesse parce qu'il sait
très bien aussi que nos sociétés
maintenant sont tellement un terrain
connecter sur que si on fait ça en bas
tout est régi par l'électricité et par
un très bon des bois à coeur
robin des bois c'est quoi l'histoire
alors les câbles sous marins en plus de
représenter internet c'est aussi tout ce
qui est transactions bancaires
aujourd'hui au swift passe par zone donc
ça serait catastrophique sur tout un tas
d'industrie c'est aussi peut-être pour
ça que elon musk à déployer le réseau
sardines en ukraine il ya à peu près
cinq jours pour justement permettre aux
ukrainiens et au gouvernement d'avoir de
pouvoir changer de fusil d'épaulé en
fait si un jour il ya un problème mais
que c'est c'est vraiment important fait
de semer aujourd'hui tout le monde
pourrait le faire mais la russie peut se
dire j'en vois quoi des hommes couper le
câble et non pas des hommes ça demande
quand même atteint de l'équipement c'est
assez conséquent parce que des fois
c'est très profondément et donc il faut
avoir quand même des bathyscaphes des
sous marins qui peuvent aller jusqu'à
6000 mètres de profondeur ils peuvent le
faire ils peuvent le faire ils ont les
moyens de le faire ça ils ont ils ont
déjà fait